hey everyone welcome to the simple
channel and today we are having a quiz
on java and kotlin
we would request you to bear with us as
we will wait for a few more minutes for
people to join the stream also to take
part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use the mobile phone and
visit the website
www.menti.com and use the code that is
mentioned on the screen
you can also use a different tab on the
browser to take part in the quiz
so let's just wait for few more minutes
for people to join the stream
if you want to make a career in java or
kotlin then you must be well versed in
the field and what better way to test
your knowledge than to take a quiz
so we will be proceeding with the quiz
soon
let's wait for a few more people to join
before we begin
also guys be sure to stick around till
the end of this quiz for a chance to win
amazon vouchers if you are one of the
top three winners
to take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone to
visit the website
www.menti.com and use the code that is
mentioned on the screen
you can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but our
live stream will be broadcasting the
results as soon as the answers are given
by the participants
so it's beneficial to have both the
screens visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the questions the
quicker you will answer the more points
you will get so be sure to think fast
and click faster
all right so while we wait for others to
join let's take a quick look at what is
java programming language what is java
used for the features of java language
and then we will understand about kotlin
language and why it was introduced
so we are going to wait for a few more
minutes
to let other people join before starting
a quiz today
so let's understand what is java
so
first of all java is a
object-oriented programming language
that was introduced by john storstru
so this language
powers billions of devices such as
computers mobile devices gaming consoles
and medical equipments and many more
the java software platform is made up of
three components the jvm the java api
and a complete development environment
now coming to the topic which is
what is java used for
so java is commonly used for web
consoles graphical user interfaces web
and mobile apps game development
embedded devices and desktop
applications
aside from these java is used to create
software for gadgets it is utilized not
just in computers and mobile devices but
also in other electrical equipment such
as televisions air conditioners and
washing machines
java has changed over time as oracle
maintains the language and releases
upgrades on a regular basis
the support of a large develop developer
community is also a distinct advantage
for new java programmers
java is a straightforward and quick to
understand and it also includes a class
loader for loading classes into the
runtime environment
java is called object oriented language
everything in java is regarded as an
object with features such as class
encapsulation abstraction inheritance
and polymorphism
now let's understand the features of
java
so java has a simple syntax that is very
easy to understand and learn
java is regarded as a robust and
powerful programming language due to its
excellent memory management
java comprises of features like garbage
collectors and exception handling
java is also known as a portable
language because java code can run on
all major platforms
this byte code format is a platform
independent and may run on any machine
it also provides security java programs
can be run on any machine that has java
runtime environment installed
java is a secure language and can
perform multitasking
java is a high performance language as
well its performance is greater than
many other languages
so as we have understood about java now
let's move on to kotlin
so first of all let's understand what is
scotland so kotlin is an open source
statically typed language designed by
jetbrains it has both the features of
object-oriented programming and
functional programming
kotlin is interoperable with java which
means both the languages can share the
use share and use information and just
like java compiler cortland compiler
also generates the bytecode which can
run on jvm
also we can say kotlin is a kind of java
with some added features even the java
libraries can also be used in kotlin
project
although java is really cool language
the developers of kotlin focused more on
simplifying the code and increasing the
transparency
all right now let's understand why
kotlin language was introduced so the
developers of jetbrains were fed up with
the repetitive code so they wanted a
much more modern language
so
to solve this problem
the team decided to create a language
that is compatible with java and with
all the features they wanted
so then they created the kotlin language
the development of quartering language
was announced in the year 2011 in 2012
the first web demo of kotlin was
released along with the new logo and
became an open source
then in 2014 kotlin lang.org was
released along with some features to
increase the interoperability with java
in the year 2015 some new features were
added like companion objects multiple
constructors etc
in the year 2017 google announced the
first class support for cortney on
android
later kotlin 1.2 was released with
features like sharing code between jvm
and javascript etc
all right so let's start with the java
and kotlin quiz now
also to take part in the quiz it is
highly recommended to use your mobile
phone
and to visit the and to
take part in this quiz you have to visit
the website
www.menti.com and use the code which is
mentioned on the screen
so the code is eight one nine two zero
one nine seven
zero nine one seven
you have to visit this website
www.menti.com and you have to enter the
code eight one nine two zero nine one
seven guys
viewers please join the link we are
getting started
let's just wait for more people to join
again guys to join the quiz
www.menti.com there you have to visit
and you have to enter the code 81920917
come on guys
just take part in this quiz and you can
get a chance to win amazon vouchers
the top three scorers will have a chance
to win the amazon vouchers
so
it's a good deal
come on guys
you can't answer in the comments box you
have to join the quiz and to join the
quiz you have to visit www.menti.com
and use the code
81920917 that is mentioned on the screen
all right viewers please join the link
we are getting started
all right
let's start with the first question
which is
in java whenever an array is passed to
the function what does that function
receive
a copy of the array b length of the
array c copy of the first element or d
reference of the array
whenever an array is passed to the
function what does the function receive
you have to pick the correct option and
you have 10 seconds left
come on guys
let's select the correct option
three two one
and here's time's up now let's have a
look at the correct option now
so the correct option is option d which
is reference of the array so most of the
folks manage to give the right answer
so
when we pass an array to a method as an
argument actually the reference of the
array in the memory is passed to the
method or function
no copy of the array no length of the
array and no copy of the first element
is passed only and only the reference of
error is passed that is why if we do any
changes in the array that will affect
the actual array values
all right
so now let's have a look at the
leaderboard
right so as we can see
at first position we have
hoshil then second position we have god
then
mala lopulu
different names as we can see
so very well guys so
try to
select the correct option in order to
elevate the first position
let's move on to the next question now
right question number two
be ready guys
so question number two is which among
the following are the types of
constructors in kotlin
so option a is primary and secondary
constructor option b is parameterized
and constant constructor option c is
default and no argument constructor and
option d is none of the above
so we have to pick the correct option
which among the following are the types
of constructors so we have to pick the
types of constructors
we have few seconds left
right now times up so here we go now
let's see the correct option which is
option a so 10 people managed to give
the correct option that is option a
primary and secondary constructor so
yeah the primary and secondary
constructors are the two types of
constructors in kotlin the class is
initialized using the primary
constructor it is specified by the class
header
the primary constructor code is enclosed
in parentheses and includes an optional
parameter
and to initialize a set of values the
secondary constructor is used so a class
can have one or more secondary
constructor as well so yeah the correct
option is option a
now moving on
to the leaderboard
now let's see
who has given the fastest option
selected the correct option fastest
so as we can see
hoshi is again at the number one and god
is at number two
nothing changed guys try to
click faster and think faster then only
you'll be able to
manage to
secure the first three positions
alright
now
moving on to the third question
which is
on your screen
right so select the correct definition
of the package so we have to pick the
correct definition of package
so
option a a package is a collection of
editing tools option b a package is a
collection of classes and interfaces
option c a package is a collection of
classes option d a package is a
collection of interfaces we have to
select the correct definition of package
there are four options pick the correct
option as soon as you can
let's see
right guys now time's up
so the correct option is option six six
people manage to give the correct option
all right so packages are basically
collections of classes and interfaces
they are used
in java to avoid the naming conf naming
complex conflicts limit access and make
search or locating and utilizing classes
and interfaces easier
so that is the correct definition of
package
now moving on to the leaderboards
all right as we can see hoshil again is
at position one god is at position two
and then other peoples have joined
prashanth is at position five i believe
so
i think there are there is some issue
with the
streaming
sorry for the technical issue guys and